[Musik]
China reicht der Mitte
eine wirtschaftliche Weltmacht die sich
nicht nur durch ihre weitreichende
Kultur sondern auch durch ihre
zukunftsweisende Technologie präsentiert
in vielen Bereichen der Industrie ist
China eines der führenden Länder doch
nicht für alle neuen Technologien
scheint das Land offen zu sein die
kryptoindustrie mit ihren Männern ist
der Wirtschaftsmacht ein Dorn im Auge
china hat alle kryptotransaktionen
verboten und auch angekündigt dass
mining von digitalen Vermögenswerten zu
unterbinden der bisher härteste Schlag
gegen die Branche
[Musik]
die Volksrepublik China ist nicht
begeistert wenn es um die Stars in der
kryptowährung geht und gerade die Nummer
eins Bitcoin hat seit seiner Erfindung
mit China einen langen intensiven Disput
hinter sich der Handel der ältesten
kryptowährung der Welt ist in der
Volksrepublik China nicht gern gesehen
und das nachdem China Bitcoin erst zu
seinem heutigen rum verholfen hat
schließlich haben wir es den zahlreichen
Pionieren und mainern aus China zu
verdanken dass Länder wie El Salvador
oder Venezuela Bitcoin als alternatives
Zahlungsmittel anbieten dennoch ist die
ablehnende Haltung der chinesischen
Regierung gegenüber der kryptowährung im
Laufe der Zeit immer deutlicher und
schärfer geworden
aber die chinesischen Behörden gehen
hier noch weiter um den krypto-handel zu
unterbinden
kryptotransaktionen werden als illegale
Finanzaktivitäten betrachtet
einschließlich der von offshore-börsen
angebotenen Dienstleistungen so die
peoples Bank of China auf ihrer Website
sie fügte hinzu dass kryptowährungen
einschließlich Bitcoin und Tessa keine
realen fiatwährungen sind und somit
nicht in Umlauf gebracht werden können
der Bitcoin brach nach der Ankündigung
ein und fiel um 8% auf etwa 43.000
US-Dollar betrug Geldwäsche und
übermäßiger Energieverbrauch werden mit
kryptowährungen in Verbindung gebracht
der enorme Energieverbrauch des Krypto
minings ist auch ein Grund dafür dass
die gesamte krypto-branche unter die
Lupe genommen wird die chinesische
wirtschaftsplanungsbehörde erklärte dass
es ihre Aufgabe sei hart durchzugreifen
und das Krypto mining zu unterbinden um
die gesetzten Klimaziele der Regierung
nicht zu gefährden
China sieht sich mit einer schweren
Energiekrise konfrontiert die bereits
Rohstoffe wie Aluminium oder Stahl in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen hat das Land
beherbergt fast 50 Prozent der
weltweiten kryptomeiner und hatte einen
Anteil von 46% der globalen hashtrate
eine Maß für die bei mining und der
Verarbeitung verwendeten Rechenleistung
wird Bitcoin und die kryptoindustrie
sich auch ohne China durchsetzen können
was sagen Analysten und Expertinnen zu
den jüngsten Entwicklungen in China
kommen wir nun zu China es sieht so aus
als ob sie es dieses Mal ernst meinen
sie verschärfen stark die Sanktionen
gegenüber kryptowährungen die ppoc
erklärt auf ihrer Website dass sie alle
Transaktionen verbieten bzw alle
kryptotransaktionen nun illegal sind
der bitcoin-kurs fällt in diesem Moment
unter 44.000 sogar 43.000
sprechen wir dazu mit unserer
krypto-expertin in Asien Joana was
können wir nun von diesem Schritt
erwarten
es klingt so als ob alles außer das
Halten von kryptos nun illegal ist ist
das richtig
hallo mad das sieht ganz so aus aber die
Frage bei solchen Regulierungen ist ja
immer was bedeutet das in der Praxis wie
Sie wissen hat China im Laufe der Jahre
schon mehrfach versucht hat
durchzugreifen aber die Menschen haben
es geschafft die Maßnahmen zu umgehen
und sind zum Beispiel auf andere Börsen
ausgewichen es gibt immer noch eine
Menge Leute die kryptowährungen halten
und ich denke wir werden kein besonders
großen Rückgang von Bitcoin oder einen
allgemeinen Rückgang von kryptos sehen
was wir bisher gesehen haben ist für
Krypto eigentlich kein großes Problem es
ist also keine große Überraschung für
den Markt allerdings wird es auch nicht
gerade die Preise steigen lassen das ist
richtig
Joana warum passiert das gerade jetzt
gab es hierfür einen Auslöser ist es
vielleicht nur ein Ablenkungsmanöver um
von der momentanen-krise abzulenken
sie beobachten natürlich wie andere
Regulierungsbehörden wie zum Beispiel
die SSC in den USA hier Schritte
unternimmt und versucht ebenfalls hart
durchzugreifen aber China hat die Dinge
schon immer auf seine eigene Art
geregelt es ist natürlich möglich dass
Sie versuchen den Fokus auf everground
abzuschwächen aber China könnte die
kryptoindustrie als Ganzes betrachten
und sagen es ist an der Zeit etwas zu
tun und das könnten Sie natürlich auch
schon beschlossen haben bevor aber Grant
große Aufmerksamkeit erregte
bestätige Fahrt das Kleinanleger bei
Spekulationen mit diesen Vermögenswerten
auf der Strecke bleiben oder werden
wohlhabende Chinesen es als Chance
nutzen um ihr Vermögen ins Ausland zu
verlagern
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich ist es etwas von beidem
und wie gesagt ich weiß es nicht aus
erster Hand aber es gibt natürlich
Spekulationen in diese Richtung aber bei
all den Spekulationen sollte man im Auge
behalten dass tapfer der von vielen als
Indikator für den Fluss von
kryptowährungen aus China angesehen wird
99% seines Preises also ungefähr 1
Dollar gehalten hat und das ist sehr
interessant
kommen wir nun direkt zu Eddie Van der
Wald unserem großen Krypto Beobachter
und Bloomberg live-strategen also er die
erst einmal guten Morgen wir versuchen
hier herauszufinden wie weit die Sache
noch gehen wird richtig china hatte den
Bitcoin ja bereits den Krieg erklärt und
dies scheint nun ein weiterer Schritt in
Richtung eines vollständigen Verbots zu
sein
also wenn sie wirklich keine
Transaktionen mehr zulassen fühlt es
sich schon sehr nach Eskalation an aber
was heißt das genau bedeutet es ich kann
keine cryptus mehr kaufen oder bedeutet
es dass ich generell keine Transaktionen
mehr durchführen kann kann ich keine
Bitcoins mehr von meinem Telefon
verschicken oder an einer Börse damit
handeln ich bin mir immer noch nicht
ganz im Klaren darüber was das genau
bedeutet und was Transaktionen unter
diesen besonderen Umständen bedeutet
aber China macht jetzt also ernst und
bitcoin ist im Moment noch auf China und
chinesische Investoren angewiesen es
gibt sehr viele chinesische Investoren
die Bitcoin seit langem nutzen und es
mit aufgebaut haben wir werden sehen wie
sehr die kryptopreise auf dieser
Verschärfung reagieren
interessant Francine spricht hier einen
wichtigen Punkt an dieses schrittweise
Vorgehen erst haben sie krypto-börsen
verboten dann das mining und jetzt sieht
es so aus als ob alle krypto-bezogenen
Transaktionen illegal sind
für mich bedeutet das jede Transaktion
ob handeln kaufen Dienstleistungen oder
zwischen Freunden verschicken völlig
egal absolut jede Art von Krypto
bezogenen Transaktionen
wenn man sich nur den Preis ansieht
scheint es Bitcoin nicht so hart
getroffen zu haben im Moment sehen wir
einen Rückgang von drei Prozent er liegt
aber noch bei
43.351 wie wichtig ist der chinesische
Markt für Bitcoin
der chinesische Markt ist für Bitcoin
extrem wichtig die Frage ist wird China
es schaffen dass alles durchzusetzen
geht es hier wirklich um ein Verbot von
Transaktionen oder nicht doch eher um
den Besitz von Bitcoin denn wenn der
Besitz weiterhin legal ist dann muss man
ja auch irgendwie damit handeln können
geht es aber nur um Transaktionen dann
ist es eine weitere Verschärfung aber
kein Verbot dann ist es allerdings auch
kein Finanzinstrument mehr denn sein wir
ehrlich Bitcoin wird nicht so oft für
Transaktionen im Finanzsystem verwendet
es wird eher als Vermögenswert gehandelt
ähnlich wie eine Aktie
entsteht gerade eine echte Grauzone
ähnlich wie mit Marihuana in vielen
Staaten der USA man durfte es besitzen
aber man durfte es nicht kaufen oder
verkaufen ein Gesetz zur Beschaffung war
nicht klar geregelt sie haben nur gesagt
dass man es besitzen aber weder kaufen
noch verkaufen darf das könnte nur noch
bei Bitcoin der Fall sein
ich glaube jedem ist klar welche
Richtung China hier jetzt einschlägt wir
wissen dass China generell nicht gut auf
kryptowährungen zu sprechen ist vor
allem nicht bei solchen die sie nicht
kontrollieren können ein digitales asset
der Zentralbank wäre hier etwas völlig
anderes ich glaube nicht dass China dem
ganzen Spektrum der kryptowährungen den
Kampf angesagt hat
Eddy das harte durchgreifen Chinas
beschränkt sich ja leider nicht nur auf
kryptowährungen denn wie Tom McKenzie
und ja bereits berichtete versuchen sie
in allen Bereichen gegen diese riesigen
vorzugehen das gilt auch für den
Immobiliensektor wir wissen nicht ob
everground gestern seine Deadline zur
Zahlungsfrist eingehalten hat oder nicht
was denken sie wird in den nächsten 24
oder 48 Stunden passieren
wir müssen abwarten und schauen was in
China passiert vielleicht kommt es zu
einer weiteren Verschärfung
die chinesische Führung hat ein Problem
mit dem Kapitalismus im Allgemeinen und
deshalb ist es für sie schwierig zu
argumentieren wie weit der Handel und
die Spekulationen auf freien Märkten
gehen dürfen
markets people spekulatives ein ähnlich
hartes Durchgreifen ist jedenfalls auch
für ausländische firmendenkbar es ist ja
nicht so dass sie die Auswirkungen nicht
verhindern könnten sie wissen genau dass
die jeweiligen Anleihegläubiger Geld
verlieren werden das steht außer Frage
aber können sie auch verhindern dass das
Finanzsystem zusammenbricht
dabei ist sich China des Potenzials der
blockchain-technologie durchaus bewusst
und hat sogar eine eigene digitale
Währung den digitalen Hörnern eingeführt
auch hatte das chinesische Unternehmen
Tencent bereits 2007 ein Programm namens
cucon ins Leben gerufen das im eigenen
Messaging-Dienst QQ eingesetzt wurde und
auch einen eigenen Sekundärmarkt
eröffnete
infolgedessen Verbot die chinesische
Regierung 2009 die Verwendung digitaler
Währungen für den Kauf von realen Waren
und Dienstleistungen Bitcoin war einer
davon wurde aber im Verbot nicht
ausdrücklich erwähnt die Tatsache dass
die chinesische Bevölkerung bereits
Erfahrung mit digitalen Währungen hatte
kam ihm dabei aber zu Gute
[Musik]
China entwickelte sich somit im Laufe
der Jahre zum dreh- und Angelpunkt der
jungen kryptoindustrie die chinesische
Regierung beschloss unterdessen die
Entwicklung der digitalen Münze
abzuwarten was wiederum den
krypto-unternehmen die Möglichkeit
eröffnete neue Wege zu beschreiben die
erste chinesische bitcoin-börse biete
ich sie China wurde 2011 gegründet
gefolgt von den krypto-plattformen huobi
und bitmain im Jahr 2013 Unternehmen wie
bei du akzeptierten ab sofort Bitcoin
Zahlungen dies wiederum erregte die
Aufmerksamkeit der chinesischen
währungsthüter im Dezember 2013 gaben
sie bekannt dass chinesische
Finanzinstitute keine
bitcoin-transaktionen mehr durchführen
dürften sie erklärten Bitcoin zu einem
illegalen Zahlungsmittel
diese Ankündigung erfolgte zu einem
Zeitpunkt als der bitcoin-handel bereits
ein beträchtlichen Aufschwung erlebte
und sein Kurs knapp zehn Tage vor dem
Verbot zum ersten Mal die
1000-dollar-marke überschritt nach der
Ankündigung brach der Wert von Bitcoin
an der damals größten bitcoinbörse der
Welt um über 30% ein
für Insider kam Chinas Crypto verboten
nicht völlig überraschend
von dem Verbot ausgeschlossen war
allerdings das Bitcoin mining dies war
weiterhin erlaubt und günstige
Rahmenbedingungen machten China schnell
zu einem Eldorado für Bitcoin mining
Unternehmen obwohl die
Regulierungsbehörde Einzelpersonen nicht
vom bitcoin-handel abhielt riet sie den
beteiligten sich den Risiken bewusst zu
sein
wir wissen ja dass China bereits
Schritte in diese Richtung unternommen
hat aber ein gänzliches Verbot ist schon
ziemlich radikal was denken Sie was
bedeutet dieser Schritt für ein
Unternehmen wie Falcon x wissen sie
China wollte kryptowährungen ja schon
seit einigen Jahren für illegal erklären
das haben wir bereits in den Jahren 2013
und 2017 gehört es ist auch dieses Jahr
schon häufiger angedroht worden das ist
nichts ungewöhnliches für ein
autoritäres Regime das versucht seine
eigene digitale Währung zu schützen
hinzu kommt das nächste Woche der
chinesische Nationalfeiertag ist ihr
hattet Durchgreifen gegen Krypto und da
bin ich wirklich einer Meinung mit
Senator petumi ist eine große Chance für
die Vereinigten Staaten wir müssen uns
an unseren strukturellen Vorteil
gegenüber China erinnern und wie App
bereits erwähnt hat waren die
Marktbewegungen historisch gesehen nicht
sehr dramatisch da haben wir in der
Vergangenheit schon Schlimmeres gesehen
natürlich sehen wir zurzeit eine tief
rote Kerze nach unten ausgelöst durch
schnelle Panikverkäufe aber
weitestgehend auf asiatischer Seite zum
Beispiel durch die in Asien Hedgefonds
wahrscheinlich gefolgt von einer
schnellen Markterholung für BTC durch
amerikanische Institutionen oder Anleger
wer ist hier Gewinner und wer Verlierer
können Sie konkret in Bezug auf die
Coins erklären was dies genau bedeutet
das würde uns helfen die Situation zu
verstehen
ja dazu ja das ist wirklich eine sehr
gute Frage ich denke historisch gesehen
wuchsen wir in den letzten zwei Monaten
in Hinblick auf unsere bottom line etwas
langsamer wir sehen heute sieben Mal
mehr Volumen in der kryptowährung und im
traditionellen Finanzwesen als in den
Wochen davor
der Fokus liegt hier natürlich in erster
Linie auf den bekannteren Coins wir
haben bereits über ethereum gesprochen
aber auch Avalanche Solana AIDA oder
Luna bewegten sich parallel zu Bitcoin
darüber hinaus auch ein paar Token die
am Rand zu Bitcoin agieren in erster
Linie sehen wir ein wiedererwachtes
Interesse an sogenannten play to earn
Token wie whigg oder exy Infinity
wie Sie wissen will China ja auch gegen
jeden ermitteln der für
kryptowährungsbörsen in Übersee arbeitet
würden darunter nicht auch alle
mitarbeiter:innen von Falcon Ex fallen
ich meine was bedeutet das für Falcon Ex
und die Arbeit in Ihrem Unternehmen
nun wir haben heute Niederlassungen in
den USA und unsere asiatische
Niederlassung befindet sich in Indien
somit hat dies also keine direkten
Auswirkungen auf unser Geschäft aber wie
sich schon sagten ist das auf jeden Fall
ein Thema für jedes Unternehmen das
mitarbeiter:innen in China beschäftigt
da jetzt in Asien das früher so etwas
wie das Zentrum der Krypto Innovation
war kryptowährung strenger reguliert
wird wird man sich auch hier in den
Vereinigten Staaten auf härtere
Maßnahmen einstellen müssen auch in
Europa erwartet man eine Verschärfung
der Regulierungen wenn wir demnächst
auch hier ein härteres Durchgreifen
sehen woher wird dann in Zukunft das
Wachstum kommen
ja das ist eine sehr gute Frage also
wenn wir nun mal das mining das China ja
bereits weitläufig verboten hat als
Beispiel nehmen sehen wir das viele
dieser Mailer nun in die Vereinigten
Staaten umsiedeln die hashtraid liegt
also bei fast 70% des Wertes Vor dem
Verbot wir haben uns also fast
vollständig davon erholt hinzu kommt
dass viele meiner heute in den USA
sitzen und wir sehen wie die Community
und die Innovationen den Vereinigten
Staaten wächst und um noch einmal darauf
zurückzukommen es ist wirklich eine
großartige Gelegenheit für die USA zu
zeigen dass wir bei der Zusammenarbeit
mit dieser Industrie an vorderster Front
stehen ich denke dass alle Beteiligten
versuchen die verbraucher:innen zu
schützen ohne hier Innovation zu
ersticken das hat für jedes Unternehmen
in diesem Bereich oberste Priorität
2015 machten chinesische Bitcoin
mining-unternehmen die Hälfte der
Bitcoin Hash rate aus
die ersten zusätzlichen kryptowährungen
durch sogenannte indische coin offerings
ICO wurden 2016 geschaffen durch icos
können Fiat Geld oder andere etablierte
Cryptos gegen Token einer digitalen
Währung getauscht werden im Herbst 2017
hatten chinesische icos über 400
Millionen Dollar eingesammelt und die
chinesische Regierung alarmiert in dem
Versuch den schwächelnden schüren zu
stützen und den illegalen Geldabfluss
aus China zu verhindern begann die
Zentralbank des Landes im januar 2017
die Aktivitäten von krypto-börsen zu
untersuchen die Untersuchung
konzentrierte sich auf die
Vorgehensweise der Börsen beim
devisenmanagement und bei der
Geldwäschebekämpfung
die peoples Bank of China hielt icos für
einen illegalen Mechanismus zur
Mittelbeschaffung sie verbot den
Plattformen die Ausgabe von Token und
ordnete an dass die über ICO
eingenommenen Gelder an die
investor:innen zurückgegeben werden
müssten die aussichtsbehörde stellte
unter anderem fest dass icos die
Stabilität der Wirtschaft des Landes
bedrohen und das Risiko eines
geschäftsausfalls Bergen
die Anordnung legte auch fest dass
Finanzinstitute und
nichtbankzahlungsunternehmen keine
Dienstleistungen anbieten dürften die
tokenbasierte fundraising-aktivitäten
unterstützten während Chinas
kryptow-gemeinschaft noch dabei war
diese neue Realität zu verarbeiten
erließen die Regulierungsbehörden eine
weitere Anweisung nur zwei Wochen später
wurden krypto-börsen auf denen der
Umtausch von Fiat zu Krypto Geld möglich
war endgültig verboten infolgedessen
verlagerten zahlreiche
bitcoin-plattformen ihre Aktivitäten ins
Ausland während andere gezwungen waren
ihre Plattformen ganz zu schließen
was haben Sie gedacht als sie von Chinas
Vorstoß hörten
ich denke wir haben die
Widerstandsfähigkeit der krypto-märkte
gegenüber einer sich annähernden
Regulierung und insbesondere einer sich
ändernden Regulierungen in China schon
mehrmals gesehen es ist schwer
vorherzusagen wie sich eine Verschärfung
auf die Gatekeeper oder die
verschiedenen Akteure auf dem Markt
auswirkt aber es ist klar dass es
unmöglich ist Bitcoin selbst zu
regulieren da die Nutzung des
dezentralen Protokolls ob nun Bitcoin
oder andere kryptos nicht reguliert
werden kann
ich denke es gibt eine Menge
Diskussionen darüber dass es im
September 2017 auch eine Art großes
china-verbot für kryptowährungen und
Börsen gab
danach sahen wir so etwas wie die erste
große kryptourelle des Jahres 2017
worauf Bitcoin ein neues Rekordhoch
erreichte
Regulierungen von Bitcoin funktionieren
ähnlich wie bei einer Hydra schlägt man
einen Kopf ab bekommt man dafür fünf
weitere Köpfe
Definition
gerade als ein mehrköpfiges Monster
beschrieben okay das lassen wir einfach
mal so stehen aber um auf ihren Punkt
zurückzukommen es ist ja das Argument
vieler Bitcoin Enthusiasten dass eine
Menge Leute mit Bitcoin handeln und ist
viele unterschiedliche Wege geben wird
mit Bitcoin handeln zu können doch wenn
China wirklich beschließt man darf
Bitcoin nicht besitzen nicht benutzen
und auch nicht handeln ich meine
inwiefern kann das keine ernsten
Auswirkungen auf den Preis und das
Volumen von Krypto haben
die globale Weltwirtschaft ist halt viel
größer als ein einzelner Staat wir sehen
übrigens auch einen Wandel von
hyperlokalen Kapitalmärkten auf denen
nur lokal gehandelt wird hin zu globalen
Kapitalmärkten und krypto-märkte sind
natürlich hyperglobal und somit das
Gegenteil von lokalen Kapitalmärkten
es wird definitiv immer Auswirkungen
verschiedener Regulierungen auf den
kryptomarkt geben aber ich denke wir
werden wieder die Widerstandsfähigkeit
eines globalen dezentralisierten
Geldsystems sehen und wir werden in
diesem Jahr eine aufregende Verschiebung
mehr in Richtung Defy also zu
verschiedenen dezentralisierten
Protokollen und Finanzsystemen sehen die
Branche wird sich stärker in Richtung
Defy bewegen
natürlich ist das Risiko viel größer und
ich denke wir sind uns einig dass andere
kryptowährungen eine größere Bedrohung
für die Zentralbanken darstellen als
Bitcoin der wohl mehr oder weniger eine
Klasse für sich ist Zentralbanken
insbesondere die Federal Reserve und
sicherlich auch die EZB werden sich hier
ebenso einmischen und dann entscheiden
können wie wann und in welcher Form
Crypt sogar handelt werden soll auch
könnten die Zentralbanken ihre eigene
digitale Währung auf Fiat Basis
durchsetzen wie groß ist dieses Risiko
dass wir sowas wie in China hier bei uns
sehen könnten
sie wissen ich bin Optimist jedes Risiko
ist auch eine Chance es besteht kein
Zweifel dass die Digitalisierung das
Geld des begonnen hat und wir bereits
die weitgehende digitale Transformation
des Geldes sehen können die
blockchain-technologie und der Bitcoin
stehen für eine neue Art von
Globalisierung
Regierungen und Behörden werden
natürlich nach Möglichkeiten suchen sie
zu regulieren wir werden viele
Zentralbanken und Regierungen sehen die
versuchen werden ihre eigenen digitalen
Währungen einzuführen ich denke das wird
parallel zu den bisherigen kryptomärkten
laufen eine andere Art von Vermögenswert
dieser gesamte Prozess die Verlagerung
des gesamten Geldsystems in den
digitalen Bereich ist eine Art
Wettrüsten zwischen vielen verschiedenen
Ländern auf der ganzen Welt
Joni eine letzte kurze Frage gab es seit
Chinas Kündigung Veränderung im Handel
auf ihrer Plattform
nun wir sehen ein generelles
handelsmuster das sich in der
Volatilität widerspiegelt wenn die
Volatilität hoch ist sehen wir mehr
Handelsaktivität und der Preis steigt
im Mai sahen wir eine Preiskorrektur von
Bitcoin nach dem miningverbot Anfang
August an das Erwachen vieler
defy-protokolle das Bitcoin und auch ETA
ebenfalls deutlich wiederbelebt hat
ich glaube dass die Märkte nach dieser
Korrektur etwas ausgeglichener sind als
noch vor einem Monat
als Folge dieser Entwicklung verlagerten
einige in China ansässige Börsen ihren
Betrieb in andere Länder während auch
viele ihre Geschäfte einstellen mussten
im April 2019 bezeichnete Chinas
nationale Entwicklungs- und
Reformkommission Andy RC das Bitcoin
mining als unerwünschte Industrie in
ihrer vorläufigen Liste von Sektoren die
von lokalen Regierungen gefördert
eingeschränkt oder abgeschafft werden
sollten Bitcoin mining ein
computerintensiver Prozess zur
Validierung von bitcoin-transaktionen
viel in den Katalog die die Behörde als
besonders umweltschädlich einstufte wie
zu erwarten war löste diese Entwicklung
eine gewisse Panik aus da ein
erheblicher Prozentsatz der Bitcoin
mining Rigs in China hergestellt wurde
außerdem war mehr als die Hälfte der
weltweiten Bitcoin mining Leistung in
China angesiedelt da die Betreiber dort
Zugang zu billigen Strom hatten
obwohl die Andy RC das Bitcoin mining
nach reiflicher Überlegung schließlich
aus ihrem endgültigen entwurfstrich war
die ganze Episode ein erster
Vorgeschmack auf das was noch kommen
sollte
brechen wir über die neuesten Meldungen
aus China inwiefern unterscheiden sich
diese von früheren Meldungen und warum
glauben sie hat der Markt sie so schnell
abgeschmettert
wie ja genau guten Morgen Yvonne schön
wieder hier zu sein das jüngste Verbot
ist nur eine weitere Verschärfung der
krypto-politik in China seit Sommer gibt
es Gerüchte dass China irgendwann vom
kryptobersenmarkt abgeschnitten sein
wird wie Sie vielleicht wissen haben
Pipi und die Regulierungsbehörden
bereits vor vier Jahren einheimische
Börsen in China verboten darauf wurden
viele der Börsen einfach ins Ausland
verlegt
wir erreichen unsere Kunden auf dem
chinesischen Festland immer noch da sie
einen VPN-Zugang nutzen können wenn Sie
also von kryptotransaktionen sprechen
ist dieses verboten meiner Meinung nach
ein kleiner Interpretationsfehler es
geht wirklich um Krypto Käufe und
Verkäufe die krypto-tausch Transaktionen
die auf börsenplattformen stattfinden
ich glaube das private Börsen die von
privaten Verkäufern betrieben werden
weiterhin erlaubt sind es dreht sich nur
um die durch Unternehmen geführten
Börsen dieses Vorgehen wird jetzt als
illegal angesehen und strafrechtlich
verfolgt
auf diesem Grund haben die großen
börsenplattformen in China in den
letzten zwei Tagen angekündigt die
Registrierung chinesischer Nutzer zu
stoppen
Bobby was glauben sie ist der Grund für
das Festhalten Chinas an diesen harten
Kurs gegen kryptowährungen ist es immer
noch die Sorge um das Risiko der
Geldwäsche durch kryptowährungen oder
geht es jetzt eher um Energieverbrauch
oder die Gefahr einer digitalen
Bedrohung für den rinnenbi was glauben
Sie treib Peking an
ich denke es hat eine Menge mit
kontrollierbarer Währung zu tun sie
wissen schon in einem System mit dem
alles kontrolliert wird wie die Wiesen
etc will man natürlich Fremdwährungen
kontrollieren Sie möchten Schlupflöcher
oder Instrumente verhindern die es
möglich machen Vermögenswerte ins
Ausland zu verschieben das ist der Grund
um Kontrolle über die Wirtschaft und
Finanzen bzw den Geldabfluss zu behalten
letzten Endes geht es bei miningverbot
nicht um die Energie ich glaube sie
versuchen hier eine Angleichung aller
kryptowährungen zu erreichen durch das
mining-verbot aber wie bereits Kontakt
halte ich das nicht für den Todesstoß
der das sogenannte illegale halten von
kryptovermögenswerten sein soll das ist
eindeutig nicht der Fall
wir berichten uns schon seit Wochen und
Monaten über die Krypto meiner in China
viele Weichen nun ins Ausland aus Bobby
sie sind ja vor Ort in Shanghai können
Sie einschätzen wie sich die Aktivität
tatsächlich bisher verlagert hat
ein großer Teil des traditionellen
minings von kryptowährungen das
sogenannte proof of power ist ins
Ausland verlagert worden wie wir es zum
Beispiel bei Bitcoin litecoin und
differium sehen es gibt eine neue
Kategorie von mining bei der es um proof
of Steak geht also um die Lagerung wie
bei Fossil coin und anderen Assets diese
werden weiterhin in China Betrieben weil
es viel schwieriger ist sie zu
lokalisieren es handelt sich dabei um
ganz normale Computer die mit Solid
State Drives ausgerüstet sind es ist
sehr schwer diesen relativ normalen
Energiebedarf als Leistungsnachweis für
smiling zu klassifizieren
[Musik]
okay Bobby vielleicht sagen sie uns noch
wie momentan die Aussichten sind was ist
ihre Prognose sie sprachen davon dass
frühere Maßnahmen aus Peking zu einem
erneuten Boom des bitcoin-kreises
geführt haben glauben Sie dass es dieses
Mal ähnlich sein wird
ja es ist so eine Sache mit diesen
Gerüchten oft werden diese als
Nachrichten verkauft also Salon roomer
Bayern News und so etwas passiert hier
auch gerade
das Gerücht dass Jena an diesem Jahr
sehr hart gegen Bitcoin Vorgehen wird
hält sich schon seit einigen Monaten nun
ist der Hammer endlich gefallen es
erinnert mich an 2017 als im September
hart durchgegriffen wurde und darauf die
bitcoin-preise gegen Ende 2017 auf ein
mehrjahres hochgestiegen sind
different dieses Jahr wird es wohl nicht
anders laufen wenn die schlechten
Nachrichten aus dem Weg geräumt sind
denke ich reagierte kryptomarkt sehr
bullisch vor allem für die klärende
jahresend Rallye erwarte ich dass die
bitcoin-preise in den nächsten Wochen
und Monaten wieder ausbrechen
nun gut wir bewegen uns immer noch um
die 43.000 Marke und sind über das
Wochenende sogar unter diesem Marke
gefallen
okay aber ich frage mich nur warum
63.000 ist immer noch weit weg was
glauben Sie wie sich die Preise
tatsächlich entwickeln werden wenn wir
von der bevorstehenden Jahres and Rallye
sprechen
so Eier ich denke das Preise über
100.000 Dollar durchaus möglich sind und
je nachdem wie stark die Rallye verläuft
waren sogar die 200er Marke oder Höhe
erreicht
natürlich wären 200.000 Dollar ein
echter Meilenstein es wird wieder eine
Menge Berichte hierzu geben und das
führt wahrscheinlich zu einer weiteren
fowmore-rallye also einer Angst etwas zu
verpassen Rallye so etwas passiert im
allgemeinen alle paar Jahre und ich
denke dass eine erneute Rallye für
Bitcoin schon lange fällig ist
wir sind gleich am Ende unseres Beitrags
Bobby wir haben ein hartes Durchgreifen
der Regulierungsbehörden in China
gesehen von fintech bis hin zu Krypto
hat das in irgendeiner Weise Einfluss
auf Ihre Geschäftsbeziehungen und ihre
Arbeit mit barley ihr mein Business ja
das stimmt wir haben uns auf den Verkauf
von Hardware wallets spezialisiert daher
sind wir von den Regulierungen nicht
betroffen und da es bereits mein zweites
Startup ist wollte ich mich von Anfang
an nicht nur auf den chinesischen Markt
verlassen natürlich sind unsere Verkäufe
mit den frühen Sanktionen in China auch
zurückgegangen dies stellt für uns aber
kein großes Problem da weil wir uns
frühzeitig auf dem internationalen Markt
für kryptowährungen positioniert haben
somit machen die jüngsten Sanktionen für
Unternehmen die ihre Aktivitäten nicht
nur auf China konzentrieren keinen
Unterschied allerdings trifft es
Unternehmen die sich auf den
chinesischen Markt konzentrieren umso
mehr
nach der Erklärung des Staatsrats
begannen die Provinzregierungen
proaktive Maßnahmen zu ergreifen um das
crypto-mining zu unterbinden die
Regulierungsbehörden begründeten das
neue Vorgehen vor allem damit das
Bitcoin sehr energieintensiv sei und
eine Gefahr für die Umweltziele des
Landes darstelle
dass die kryptoindustrie intensiv an
einer umweltfreundlicheren Variante des
Bitcoins forscht wurde bereits mit dem
Skier green Token project vorgestellt
Chia wurde als der grüne altkorn
tituliert warum ist der grüner als
Bitcoin
nun zunächst einmal anstatt auf eine
Menge Strom und benutzerdefinierte
Hardware zu vertrauen um sicherzugehen
dass die blockchain korrekt funktioniert
setzen wir stattdessen auf ungenutzten
Festplattenspeicher Chia nutzt eine
Kombination aus proof of space und proof
of elapse time auch Konsens Algorithmus
genannt beim Konsens Algorithmus proof
of Philips time wird für jeden Knoten
innerhalb eines Netzwerkes eine
zufällige Zeitspanne gewählt diese
Zeitspanne musste Nutzer schlicht
abwarten welcher Nutzer nun den neuen
Block generiert entscheidet die Länge
der Wartezeit die kürzeste Wartezeit
generiert den neuen Block darf ihn in
der blockchain zuweisen und erhält die
Belohnung in coins
beim proof of space wird nicht
verwendeter Festplattenspeicher als
Speicherplatz verwendet um diesen
nachzuweisen müssen Nutzer eine Software
installieren die eine Sammlung
kryptographischer Nummern auf der
Festplatte speichert Festplatten
verbrauchen so deutlich weniger Strom
wenn man alle Festplatten die in diesem
Jahr ausgeliefert wurden was ungefähr
ein setabyte darstellt mit ethereum
vergleicht so ist das etwa 1/10 des
gesamten Energieverbrauchs pro Jahr wenn
hier also die Nachfrage steigt schafft
das dann nicht automatisch auch einen
Mehrbedarf an Speicher und Festplatten
was ja letztendlich wieder mehr
Belastung und ein weiteres Problem für
die Umwelt darstellt nun es gibt zwei
Dinge die hier wichtig sind zu
betrachten das eine ist sie wissen genau
dass ein Fahrrad viel effizienter ist
als ein Tesla aber das heißt nicht dass
wir nicht wollen dass Tesla mit SUVs
konkurriert wir sind eine sehr viel
grünere Alternative und bieten außerdem
mehr Sicherheit als Bitcoin und
destillion und wir haben etwa 500.000
Notes im Vergleich zu Bitcoins 40.000
aber was wir eigentlich tun ist dass wir
gebrauchte Festplatten wieder in den
Markt
bei kryptopharma Sie von Facebook oder
Box nach ihrer vierjährigen Einsatzdauer
abkaufen und diese Festplatten nutzen
anstatt sie auf dem Müll zu werfen
sie haben neulich erst ihren Börsengang
verkündet und so wie ich es verstehe ist
der Plan einer eigene Handelsplattform
ein breites Zahlungssystem zu entwickeln
können Sie uns sagen wie ihre Ambitionen
insgesamt Aussehen ja wir glauben dass
die blockchain im Jahr 2017 längst diese
Marktfähigkeit hätte erlangen sollen
aber es gab regulatorische Probleme und
auch die Funktionalität der blockchain
war wirklich noch nicht reif für den
Übergang auf Unternehmen oder Behörden
unsere neu entwickelte innovative
blockchain Programmiersprache Namens
chayalist ist heute sehr viel
weiterentwickelt um Dinge wie digitale
Währungen digitale Börsen Kreditmärkte
oder auch Aktien zu stützen eine Sache
die wir wirklich anders gemacht haben
ist die Unternehmensform zu wählen die
uns eine Einführung einer blockchain
erlaubt wir erwarten eine Art
redhead-geschäft aufzubauen indem wir
Unternehmen bei der Einführung der
blockchainfrastruktur unterstützen die
Idee an die Börse zu gehen ist eine
Produktstrategie für viele Unternehmen
ist es eine Art Exit-Strategie ein
Ausweg für uns stellt es einen Weg da
die Regularien zu klären es macht es uns
einfacher zu erklären dies ist unser
Kapital im Gegensatz zu unseren Coins
die eine reine Ware darstellen und es
erlaubt unseren Nutzern zum Beispiel
unser Eigenkapital zu verwenden um sich
von der Volatilität abzuschirmen die
diese Coins oft haben
nun offenbar steckt grundsätzlich eine
Menge Volatilität im kryptomarkt aber
inzwischen sieht es so aus als wäre Chia
selbst sehr volatil was halten Sie davon
ich denke Chia versucht gerade seinen
Marktpreis zu finden und wissen Sie ich
denke es pendelt sich so langsam ein
wenn man sich die letzten zwei Wochen so
ansieht lag es in der Spanne von 600 bis
700 Dollar am kryptomarkt ist das
tatsächlich eine ziemlich enge Spanne
die hier nicht gerade üblich sind sie
sagen es ist grüner als bitcoin ist es
auch grüner als asterium also die Sache
mit ist helium ist dass es bereits die
letzten zwei Jahre hieß in drei Monaten
kommt die 2.0 Version wir glauben nicht
dass der proof of Steak wirklich sicher
ist wenn es um einen zwischenstaatliche
Art von Wettbewerb geht der proof of
Steak weist noch eine Menge Probleme auf
die nach nakamoto-konsens das Bitcoin
übrigens ist und wir bereits auch noch
weit entfernt von wirklich gelöst sind
wie Sie wissen gibt es beim proof of
Steak immer noch das Problem dass 51%
Angriff der wenn er erfolgreich ist die
gesamte blockchain und ihre
Transaktionen manipuliert
aber die Antwort auf die Frage der
ökologischen Nachhaltigkeit ist nicht
alleinschlüssel zum Erfolg China gibt's
zwar immer wieder ökologische Gründe an
um weitere Regulierungen durchzusetzen
aber die Antwort auf die Frage der
ökologischen Nachhaltigkeit wo du bisher
nicht beantwortet
ist die Antwort auf die Frage der
ökologischen Nachhaltigkeit von Krypto
wirklich der Schlüssel zum Erfolg
guten Morgen danke dass ich hier sein
darf ich denke das ist eine wirklich
wichtige Frage für alle Branchen und
Unternehmen und Krypto stellt da keine
Ausnahme da es trifft nicht allein uns
ich denke dass wirklich Interessante an
der kryptow-wirtschaft ist dass sie eine
Art maximale margeneffizienz mitbringt
er sucht sich immer die günstigsten
Energiequellen und wir wissen ja dass
dies erneuerbare Energien sind
die neuesten Statistiken zeigen das
Krypto mining insbesondere das Bitcoin
mining am kostenintensivsten ist
ungefähr 50 bis 60 Prozent hiervon wird
durch erneuerbare Energien gedeckt was
weit über dem Industriedurchschnitt
liegt
es ist also noch ein langer Weg für die
kryptoindustrie und ein sehr wichtiger
Teil ihrer Geschichte die neuen Verbote
aus China die sie erwähnt haben sind nur
eine von vielen die noch kommen werden
es wird also eine größere
Herausforderung für China angenommen und
das ist etwas über das wir natürlich
nicht so glücklich sind dass
mining-verbot in China Anfang des Jahres
hat dazu geführt dass sich meiner als
Ausland verlagert haben
das mining in China macht nur noch 55%
des weltweiten Anteils aus und der wird
wahrscheinlich weiter zurückgehen und je
mehr sich das mining aus China ins
Ausland und dann andere Orte verlagert
an denen erneuerbare Energien schneller
und besser genutzt werden zum Beispiel
den USA desto mehr wird sich der
Energiemix für kryptowährungen ändern
die verschiedenen blockchains wie zum
Beispiel Bitcoin oder auch ethereum
werden sicherlich nach alternativen
Wegen suchen um ihre Netzwerke zu
sichern der proof of Steak ist eine
alternative Methode zur Sicherung dieser
Transaktionen und zur Sicherung des
distributed Ledger
viele neue Technologien neue Coins und
bereits bestehende Coins Stellen auf
diese Art von Methodik um und ich denke
das wird Auswirkungen haben
die Nachhaltigkeit des proof of Steak
wäre auch direkt meine nächste Frage
gewesen denn selbst bei den proof of
Steak basierenden blockchains sind die
Unterschiede untereinander groß richtig
ich meine in der Theorie rangiert man
hier ziemlich weit unten
nachhaltigkeit ist definitiv ein Teil
davon ich denke unsere Generation muss
sogar auf erneuerbare Energien umsteigen
damit kryptowährung sich schneller
entwickeln kann erneuerbare Energien
sind nun mal die Energiequellen der
Zukunft tatsächlich gibt es einige sehr
interessante australische Projekte wie
zum Beispiel modulare mining-projekte
jedes neue Projekt muss Teil der
Energiewende sein oder können diese
zumindest unterstützen
das mining für kryptowährungen kann
durchaus vor Ort realisiert werden ich
kenne Projekte die sich lokal ansiedeln
und mit einem Überangebot zu kämpfen
haben
in Australien gibt es ein Überangebot
wenn es um die Spitzenlast der
Solarenergie geht hier kann man diesen
modularen Ansatz im Verbrauch nutzen
bitcoin ist nicht der Feind er ist Teil
des Übergangs und ein interessantes
Werkzeug in diesem Prozess das
eigentliche Problem sind wir und unsere
Umsetzung wenn wir etwas ändern wird
sich auch die kryptoindustrie ändern
wir haben neue Experimente mit
grenzüberschreitenden digitalen
Währungen durch die Banken gesehen ganz
zu schweigen von den währungsbehörden
Chinas und Hongkongs welchen Einfluss
werden diese digitalen Währungen oder
cbdcs auf andere kryptowährungen haben
das ist eine wirklich interessante Frage
denn wir haben vor kurzem gesehen dass
Plattformen wie Twitter kryptowährungen
in Ihr Netzwerk aufgenommen haben man
kann also Leute für seine Plattform
begeistern indem man Bitcoin verwendet
und es gab einige wirklich interessante
Videos die zeigen wie Leute
grenzüberschreiten Trinkgeld geben
plötzlich ist Twitter also nicht nur ein
soziales Netzwerk sondern eine Plattform
für grenzüberschreitende Zahlungen und
genau das ist die Stärke von blockchain
und Krypto im Internet verankert können
Sie in jeder App integriert werden
interessant ist auch der Einzug
digitaler Währungen von Zentralbanken in
den letzten 12 bis 24 Monaten wurde
durch stable Coins und die Verwendung
von kryptowährungen im
grenzüberschreitenden Verkehr bewiesen
dass es sich um eine überlegene Form von
Geld handelt die Zentralbanken werden
sich diese Technologie zu Nutze machen
wissen Sie es ist eine Art Internet 3.0
in einem Land wie China werden diese
Dinge leider weiterhin nebeneinander
existieren müssen sie versuchen ihre
eigene Art von einer Währung
durchzusetzen aber die Akzeptanz zur
Technologie und im Allgemeinen ist
vorhanden
das ist sicherlich bedauerlich für
aufstrebende chinesische Unternehmen und
die chinesische Gemeinschaft die schnell
auf diese neue Art von Technologie setzt
kryptowährungen und digitale Währungen
der Zentralbanken werden in Zukunft
nebeneinander bestehen müssen
wenn es um die Einführung neuer
Technologien die Entwicklung ihrer
digitalen Währung und vielleicht auch um
Regulierung geht was denken Sie welche
Länder sind hier führend
neben den Amerikanern sind wir in
Australien natürlich eine stolze
kryptonation und haben eine gewisse
Präsenz hier vor Ort verschiedene Länder
haben verschiedene Herangehensweisen der
regulatorische Rahmen kann sich
natürlich jederzeit ändern und das trägt
natürlich eine Menge zu Akzeptanz bei
wenn sie mich jetzt fragen wer die
fortschrittlichsten krypto-länder sind
können wir natürlich nicht die Länder
unerwähnt lassen die Krypto bereits als
gesetzliches Zahlungsmittel eingeführt
haben wie zum Beispiel El Salvador aber
es gibt ebenso viel Innovation in Europa
aus der Schweiz so viele Stiftungen
ihren Sitz haben hier gibt es
interessanteste Technologien
auch in den USA gibt es eine Menge an
dynamischen und spannenden Projekten es
handelt sich um eine globale Technologie
es kommt darauf an ob die Menschen die
dort sind diese Technologie annehmen
und in Australien gibt es wirklich
faszinierende Projekte
für den Großteil des Jahres 2020
verschärfte die chinesische Regierung
ihren Blick auf krypto-börsenaktivitäten
im Rahmen einer laufenden Kampagne zur
Bekämpfung von Geldwäsche und Betrug im
August gab die ppoc ihre Absicht bekannt
über 100 ausländische Websites zu
sperren die kryptobersen anbieten die
Probleme der chinesischen
kryptoindustrie im Jahr 2021 begannen im
Mai als der Staatsrat die Einschränkung
von Krypto mining und Handel forderte
zuvor hatten die Behörden der Provinzen
Innere Mongolei synchang und Cichon die
allesamt wichtige Bitcoin mining
Drehscheiben waren damit begonnen den
Betrieb von Bitcoin Männern
einzuschränken ähnlich wie bei der
Verfolgung von kryptobörsen im Jahr 2017
waren die Bitcoin meiner gezwungen
entweder ihre Tätigkeit dauerhaft
einzustellen oder in andere
krypto-freundlichere Länder umzuziehen
da rund 50% der weltweiten Bitcoin
mining-leistung Vor dem Verbot in China
erzeugt wurde bekam die alle
bitcoin-wirtschaft erwartungsgemäß die
Auswirkungen des Verbots zu spüren
was halten Sie davon dass ich Peking
immer mehr von kryptowährungen abwendet
guten Morgen und vielen Dank für die
Einladung nun selbst wenn man von der
ganzen Krypto Problematik mal ab sieht
denke ich dass dies womöglich auch eine
fehlgeleitete soft power-aktion China
sein könnte um anderen Ländern zu zeigen
dass man in China kein Einflussbereich
durch Krypto gewinnen kann wenn man sich
Länder wie El Salvador Laos oder
Afghanistan anschaut dann sind das alles
Länder die sich auf kryptowährungen
zubewegen während China sich zurückzieht
wie Sie wissen haben die Chinesen
weltweit viel Mühe und Ressourcen
investiert um ihre Einflussnahme zu
stärken vor allem in Lateinamerika und
in den Ländern und Regionen in denen ihr
Einfluss schwindet wird es in Zukunft
Probleme geben
ja wir haben sogar gesehen wie FTX ihren
Hauptsitz von Hongkong auf die Bahamas
verlegt haben diese Verlagerung nach
Lateinamerika die sie erwähnten was dass
in der Praxis für Unternehmen die
Beziehungen zu China haben und
insbesondere für die chinesischen
nutzer:innen
ja das ist durchaus richtig wenn man
sich mal die beiden größten
Handelsplätze huobi oder
ok-ex ist ja ein Gigant des chinesischen
krypto-handels bei beiden sahen wir am
Wochenende deutlich die Auswirkungen es
gab erhebliche werteverluste ihrer Token
im Handel
und sicherlich werden Unternehmen die in
China selbst agieren oder chinesische
Kunden haben über das Wochenende und
darüber hinaus Mühe haben sich zu
positionieren
für jeden Akteur der hier involviert ist
werden die kommenden Tage wichtig sein
aber ich denke auch es ist gut die
kryptoindustrie als eine eigene Branche
zu sehen die ihre Robustheit schon
mehrfach unter Beweis gestellt hat dies
ist bereits das zweite Mal in diesem
Jahr das China versucht kryptowährungen
zu verbieten
ja durch das jüngste Verbot verzeichnete
die Branche im Juni ein Einbruch des
bitcoin-preises aber wir sehen natürlich
auch was in den Monaten danach passierte
implications
und das ist ein weiterer Beweis für die
Robustheit von Krypto insbesondere wenn
man sich den globalen Markt anschaut wir
werden also mit großem Interesse
verfolgen was in China passiert aber
auch die Regulierungen in anderen
Ländern beobachten wir genau
insbesondere wie die Verlagerung des
Bitcoin minings in Richtung Westen
verlaufen wird wie wir sie im Laufe
dieses Jahres bereits beobachten konnten
also ja absolut Unternehmen die einen
direkten Handel mit Krypto in China
tätigen müssen sich Sorgen und nun
schauen was die Zukunft bringt
allerdings sehe ich keine großen
Verluste für den Rest der Branche die
Erschütterungen gewohnt und global gut
aufgestellt ist
wenn wir uns langfristig den Trend bei
Bitcoin anschauen wir sind ja immer noch
ziemlich weit vom Allzeithoch über
60.000 entfernt sehen Sie hier eine
schnelle Markt Erholung und wie viel
davon hat tatsächlich mit Nachrichten
aus China zu tun ich meine man hat das
Gefühl dass es seit 2019 für Krypto
immer schwieriger wird sich zu
stabilisieren
ja absolut ich denke dass der
Preisrückgang den wir gesehen haben auch
ein Indiz dafür ist 10% der kryptos sind
über das Wochenende um fünf bis sieben
Prozent gefallen
hinzu kommt noch Social Media zum
Beispiel heißt es auf Twitter
nutzer:innen könnten nun Bitcoin für
ihre Aktivitäten nutzen gleichzeitig
erreichen uns negative Nachrichten aus
China denen ca 330 Millionen Twitter
User gegenüberstehen die jetzt in der
Lage sein werden Bitcoin für Social
Media Transaktionen zu verwenden es
spricht vieles für einen erneuten
Aufschwung ob ich glaube dass wir wieder
einen Preis von 60.000 Dollar sehen
werden
deutet alles darauf hin dass wir uns in
diese Richtung bewegen werden glaube ich
dass wir langfristig mehr Anwendungen
für Bitcoin sehen werden auf jeden Fall
allerdings wäre es ziemlich naiv zu
sagen dass Bitcoin die einzige Option
darstellt ich denke die Geschichte hat
den Menschen immer wieder gezeigt wie
schnell sich Tauschmittel oder
Wertanlagen ändern können ich kann mir
sehr gut vorstellen dass es neben
Bitcoin eine Menge anderer Anwärter auf
den kryptotron geben wird
wenn wir nun mal auf Australien schauen
da gibt es derzeit viel Bedenken
gegenüber der kryptoindustrie zum
Beispiel bei Themen wie Nachhaltigkeit
oder Regulierungen liegt Australien im
Vergleich zu Singapur oder dem nahen
ostenwald zurück erwarten sie dass es
hier einen Innovationsschub für
kryptowährungen geben wird oder besteht
sogar die Chance dass eines dieser
Länder chinas Führung übernimmt
in der Tat ist das eine große Chance für
Australien und das ist sicherlich auch
die Botschaft die die Branche versucht
der Regierung und den
Regulierungsbehörden zu vermitteln wir
sind gespannt auf den Bericht den der
Senat noch in diesem Monat entschuldigen
Sie bitte im Oktober nächsten Jahres
vorlegen wird
die Chance ist sehr real dass ich China
wohl aus diesem Bereich zurückziehen
will für Länder wie Australien bietet
sich jetzt die Gelegenheit wirklich
voranzukommen denn wir haben die
Möglichkeit nachhaltiges Bitcoin mining
mit all den green energy solutions die
uns zur Verfügung stehen zu betreiben
wenn man sich zum Beispiel Iran anschaut
der diese Chance ergriffen hat und
inzwischen 4,5% des weltweiten Bitcoin
minings beisteuert dann zeigt uns das
welche Möglichkeiten ein solcher Schritt
bietet wir müssen uns hier fragen ob wir
diese Gelegenheit im Iran oder es
Salvador überlassen wollen oder ob
Australien das so viele Möglichkeiten
bietet in diesem Bereich auch vorangehen
sollte schauen wir uns nur die
Entwicklung Singapurs an ein echter
Leuchtturm in der krypto-branche
ich denke hier gibt es für Australien
die Möglichkeit für eine enge
Partnerschaft und Zusammenarbeit in
dieser Industrie um hier ein effizienten
und nachhaltigen Weg zu finden
Australien ist in der Lage die
kryptoindustrie sehr stark
voranzutreiben
wenn China nun auch noch versucht einen
Teil des Krypto minings zu unterbinden
wie genau werden die Preise darauf
reagieren
es war eine unglaublich volatile Woche
für den Bitcoin die jüngsten Nachrichten
aus China haben ihn wieder einmal hart
getroffen es ist das zweite Mal in
dieser Woche dass ich Nachrichten aus
China direkt auf kryptowährungen
ausgewirkt haben zuerst mit der Aussage
dass es dem Finanzsektor nicht mehr
erlaubt ist Krypto zu benutzen und dass
sie noch härter dagegen vorgehen werden
und jetzt die Nachricht über das harte
durchgreifen bei mining das hat die
Krypto Industrie noch einmal richtig
getroffen
ja ich meine das stellt viele Leute da
draußen auf die Probe es ist gut das
Krypto nicht an Wochenenden ausbrechen
kann richtig
ja eine Fangfrage
kryptowährung könnte am Wochenende
durchaus eine Verschnaufpause gebrauchen
aber sie wird weiter gehandelt und
dieses Wochenende könnten wir sogar noch
mehr Bewegungen sehen da die Volumina an
Wochenenden normalerweise geringer sind
das bedeutet vielleicht sogar noch einen
Anstieg der Volatilität
Claire wir finden es toll dass auch am
Wochenende gehandelt wird das bedeutet
Sie können auch am Samstag und Sonntag
ihrem Geliebten Job als Reporterin
nachgehen
lassen Sie uns über die zukünftige
Entwicklung nachdenken wenn solche
Kommentare aus China öfter kommen macht
das die Währung oder den krypto-raum
nicht sehr volatil was bedeutet das für
die Zukunft
nun das einzige was sicher erscheint ist
wohl die Volatilität von Bitcoin aus
Gesprächen mit anleger:innen habe ich
entnommen dass diese Bewegungen den
breiteren kryptomarkt zwar auf einer Art
und Weise beeinflussen es offensichtlich
aber nicht der Hauptfaktor ist ich denke
investor:innen die mit Aktien und
Anleihen Handeln blicken zurückhaltend
auf Bitcoin und mögen es nicht irgendwie
beeinflusst zu werden so kann man schon
eine gewisse Risikoscheu beobachten
gerade wenn Bitcoin erneut unter Druck
gerät und das könnte sich fortsetzen
ich bin neugierig ich meine wir haben
gesehen dass diese Korrelationen vor
allem in dieser Woche und letzter Woche
wirklich eine Art Parallelbewegung in
Bezug auf Krypto und einigen anderen
risikoesserts hervorgerufen haben für
viele ist Krypto eine Art Absicherung
gegen die normale Volatilität des
Aktienmarktes wenn diese Korrelation
hier fort besteht wird das vielleicht zu
einem weiteren Ausbruch führen hat schon
jemand daran gedacht
ja ein wenig denke ich die Leute
konzentrieren sich hauptsächlich auf die
Inflation und achten sehr auf eventuelle
Anzeichen es stellt sich ja auch die
Frage wie der Bitcoin reagiert wenn die
Inflation weiterhin steigt wir wissen
natürlich dass die tech-branche
steigende inflationswerte nicht mag aber
ich denke die Idee von Bitcoin als
Absicherung entwickelt sich noch weiter
und die Leute versuchen herauszufinden
was mit den Preisbewegungen am
häufigsten korreliert
[Musik]
als ob das Verbot des Bitcoin minings
nicht schon genug wäre beschlossen die
chinesischen Regulierungsbehörden im
September den krypto-handel ganz zu
verbieten die Zentralbank des Landes
räumte daraufhin in Zusammenarbeit mit
der Polizei und des Obersten
Gerichtshofs alle Zweifel an der Haltung
des Landes zu kryptowährung aus und ließ
keinen Raum für Fehlinterpretationen
die Regulierungsbehörden stuften alle
kryptotransaktionen sowohl vier zu
Krypto als auch Krypto zur Krypto den
Handel und Investitionen als illegal ein
unabhängig davon ob Sie über lokale oder
ausländische Plattformen abgewickelt
wurden dies schloss alle Bitcoin
isthereum und teilvertransaktionen ein
chinesische Staatsangehörige die im
Marketing oder im technischen Support
für ausländische Börsen arbeiteten
konnten nun strafrechtlich verfolgt
werden die Andy RC legte Pläne zum
vollständigen Ausstieg aus dem
kryptomending vor indem sie
Investitionen in den Sektor einstellte
die Stromkosten erhöhte und neuen
Unternehmen den Zugang zu Branche
verwerte wie kennt ihr schon sagte wir
haben diese Geschichte schon einmal
erlebt das ist keine allzu große
Überraschung bedeutet das einen großen
Rückschlag für die krypto-gemeinschaft
sie haben vollkommen recht und vielen
Dank dass ich hier sein darf dies ist
nicht das erste Mal dass chinesische
Regulierungsbehörden eine solche
Erklärung abgegeben haben frühere
Versuche kryptowährungen zu verbieten
verliefen ja weitestgehend in Sande
außerdem ist es bemerkenswert dass es
kurz nach der Flucht vieler meiner in
die Mongolei angekündigt wurde es ist
also etwas mehr Dynamik im Spiel was
Preisentwicklung und Fundamentaldaten
angeht
also Stefan ich bin neugierig sie haben
die heutige Kursentwicklung beobachtet
bitcoin ist um fast 9% gefallen
natürlich gibt es Coins die deutlich
stärker gefallen sind wie zum Beispiel
Isa der glaube ich um ungefähr 11%
gefallen ist Bitcoin war heute morgen
trotzdem so etwas wie ein Outperformer
wirkt er vielleicht für anleger:innen
wie eine Art Zuflucht
es ist sehr klar dass Bitcoin für viele
eine Art Zufluchtsort darstellt ich
denke auch dass es sich viel mehr um die
fundamentale Frage dreht ist Bitcoin ein
verlässlicher Vermögenswert wenn man
sieht dass er eine Art fundamentale
Unterstützung findet ist das
verständlich die Leute haben ihre
fundamentalen Metriken diese übertragen
sie auf Bitcoin hier halten wir also ein
Niveau dass wir bei einigen neueren
Coins nicht sehen diese basieren auf sie
wissen hochspekulativen Anwendungsfällen
etc ich denke diese Abverkäufe gerade
ergeben einen Sinn für BTC denke ich
gibt es noch eine Menge grundlegende
Argumente und der wird seine
Unterstützung bald finden
Lea wenn wir uns wieder der
Kursentwicklung zuwenden auch wenn es
hier keine echten Neuigkeiten zu Bitcoin
und anderen kryptowährungen gab nähern
wir uns dennoch dem Wochenende und wir
wissen ja dass der kryptomarkt an den
Wochenenden weit geöffnet ist und zu
großer Volatilität neigt was erwarten
Sie wo wir am Montagmorgen stehen
ja absolut nun die Assets scheinen ihren
Bodensatz gefunden zu haben aber wie sie
schon sagten neigen die Wochenenden dazu
sehr volatil zu sein und wie sich das
entwickeln wird kann man jetzt nur raten
bitcoin ist um etwa 10% gefallen hat bei
etwa 40.000 sein Widerstand gefunden und
sich auf etwa 41.000 erholt
IFA fiel ebenfalls um etwa 10% und liegt
immer noch deutlich unter 3000 andere
Coins fielen noch deutlicher allerdings
reagierte kardano mit einem Anstieg was
wirklich interessant ist ich vermute
also dass wir uns auf ein spannendes
Wochenende gefasst machen können
ich frage mich was das für andere Länder
bedeutet ich meine wenn China seine
Regulierungen weiter verschärft könnte
das eventuell eine Chance für andere
Länder darstellen
ich denke es herrscht noch eine Art
Verwirrung rund um das ganze Vorgehen
der chinesischen Regierung bis vor etwa
einem Jahr gab es noch eine Welle von
Krypto Befürwortern die behaupteten dass
China aufgrund des digitalen Türen einen
riesigen Vorsprung bei kryptowährungen
hätte
ich glaube nicht wirklich dass das
jemals der Fall gewesen ist China
versucht sich seit 2013 an kryptowährung
es ist ein Land mit strengen
devisenkontrollen und eine Anlageklasse
wie kryptowährungen die mehr finanzielle
Freiheit verspricht hat Ihnen schon
immer Missfallen
ich glaube nicht dass es sich hier um
einen reinen Sinneswandel handelt denn
China wollte nie bei kryptowährung
mitmischen aber vielleicht ändert es ja
die Wahrnehmung in den USA wie sie
bereits erwähnt haben könnten wir hier
China in diesem Bereich einen Schritt
voraus sein
vielleicht wird dieser Gedanke
Regulierungsbehörden zu einer
günstigeren Regulierung gegenüber den
kryp Unternehmen veranlassen ich glaube
nicht dass es sich hier nur um eine
Erneuerung frühere Aussagen und
Vorschriften handelt letztlich gab es ja
auch gute Nachrichten wie die von
Twitter
wieso Stefan und du hast ein bisschen
darüber gesprochen dass man mit Bitcoin
über deinen Twitter-Konto Trinkgeld
geben kann
ja nun das war gestern glaube ich
ja genau ganz genau innerhalb der
letzten zehn bis 24 Stunden wurde das
aktiviert ich meine sie sprechen von
einem grundlegenden Anstieg der
bitcoin-nutzung richtig man könnte
meinen dass die Menschen in China einen
Weg gefunden haben Bitcoin trotz des
Verbots zu nutzen somit also nichts
Neues
und jetzt haben wir diese sehr bekannte
hochkarätige Firma die Bitcoin für einen
echten Anwendungsfall einsetzt ich meine
es ist definitiv ein Zuwachs des
Nutzwertes außerdem gibt es so viele
verschiedene Argumente dafür dass
Bitcoin den Markt wird und in
Mechanismus verzerren könnte was ein
neues Konzept ist das ist sehr
interessant
und jetzt wie Lia erwähnte scheinen wir
hier etwas Unterstützung zu finden und
vielleicht werden sich diese positiven
Effekte durchsetzen
Lea da wir gerade von Anwendungsfällen
und anderen Ländern sprechen ich würde
auch kurz ihre Meinung zu El Salvador
hören wo Bitcoin ja gerade als legales
Zahlungsmittel eingeführt wurde ich
meine wollen Länder wie China
kryptowährungen tatsächlich komplett
verbieten immerhin ist Bitcoin nun ein
legales Zahlungsmittel eines anderen
Landes wie soll das funktionieren
ja das ist in der Tat sehr speziell ich
möchte aber kurz sagen Stefan ich bin
auch völlig begeistert dass Twitter
nicht nur eine trinkgeldfunktion für
Bitcoin eingeführt hat sondern hierfür
sogar Lightning integriert hat zu deinem
Punkt Katie ich finde es sagt bereits
viel aus dass Chinas Säbel rasseln zu
einem Zeitpunkt kommt in der der
internationale digitale Handel an Fahrt
gewinnt unsere El Salvador bleibt zu
sagen dass Bitcoin für illegal zu
erklären womöglich in Zukunft ein
Problem darstellen könnte da Bitcoin nun
zur Landeswährung El Salvadors gehört
und Geschäfte zwischen den Ländern nun
auch in Bitcoin abgewickelt werden
können ich denke dass nach diesem
Schritt El Salvadors auch andere Länder
einschließlich Costa Rica ähnliche
Schritte einleiten werden und zum
Beispiel Bitcoin als nationale Währung
akzeptieren darunter auch Länder wie die
Ukraine oder Kuba die entweder
krypto-vorschriften erlassen oder
signalisieren wie im Fall von Panama und
den USA dass diese Gesetze bald kommen
werden solange es hier funktionierende
Märkte und große Gewinne gibt wird es
sehr schwer werden kryp Veränderungen
auf globaler Ebene zu verbieten trotz
Chinas hartem durchgreifen ist das Land
ein wichtiger globaler cryptomarkt
geblieben chinesische krypto-wallets
haben bis heute Coins im Wert von rund
150 Millionen Dollar erhalten
somit liegt China weiterhin an zweiter
Stelle nach den USA so ein Bericht des
analyseanbieters Chanels
Henry arslanian
krypto-börsen in Übersee akzeptieren
noch immer keine Kunden aus den USA nun
müssen genau diese Börsen möglicherweise
auch Kunden mit Sitz in China verbieten
für die meisten globalen kryptobörsen
war die Akzeptanz von Kunden aus China
immer eine Grauzone jetzt ist diese
Unklarheit beseitigt
aber selbst wenn große Börsen für in
China ansässige Händler tabu sein
sollten sei es aufgrund der dezentralen
Struktur der Börsen sehr schwierig
Menschen davon abzuhalten in irgendeinem
Land etwas zu halten so aus Linien
die Pipi bereitet außerdem die
Einführung eines offiziellen digitalen
rinnen-b vor und wird damit zum
Vorreiter in diesem Bereich die Währung
soll während der Olympischen
Winterspiele 2022 in einem Testlauf
eingeführt werden
Leiter für digitale Anlagen beim
Vermögensverwalter wisdom tree in Europa
sagte der Versuch Chinas kryptowährungen
zu verbieten ist nur die Fortsetzung
eines Trends aber sie verschärfen die
Rhetorik im Vorfeld der Einführung des
digitalen
Partnerin bei Race capital spricht mit
Emily Cheng von Bloomberg technology
über zukünftige Strategien für
Investitionen in China im Zuge der
Turbulenzen im Land und darüber wie die
jüngste Razzia langfristig eine gute
Sache für das Crypto Ökosystem sein kann
ich bin neugierig sehen Sie Race capital
durch Chinas Verbot bedroht wie schützen
Sie Ihre Wertanlagen
in nun ich betrachte Chinas Markt eher
langfristig es ist natürlich schwer
täglich neue Meldungen und Verbote aus
China zu hören aber ich möchte alle
investor:innen noch mal daran erinnern
dass China noch immer der zweitgrößte
Markt der Welt ist mit über 1,4
Milliarden Menschen und einem
Bruttoinlandsprodukt von 15 Billionen
und darauf konzentriere ich mich im
Venture capitalbereich sehen wir uns nur
mal sekoria China Investment an sie hat
in den letzten 90 Tagen 96 Geschäfte
abschließen können per se ist hier also
kein abbremsender Wirtschaft zu erkennen
aber natürlich muss ich in China nun
jeder an die Regeln halten
dabei spielt es keine Rolle welches
Unternehmen wir uns anschauen Alibaba
Tencent oder Didi niemand kann die
chinesische Regierung überlisten oder
Ihre Vorgaben umgehen einen kleinen
Vorgeschmack der neuen chinesischen
Regelungen sahen wir bei einem
Unternehmen namens data Cook hier gibt
es sehr bald ein speculasting in der
Nasdaq geben ich denke im März
würden Sie sagen dass Sie Ihre Strategie
angesichts des harten Kurses seitens
China geändert haben gehen Sie ein
höheres Risiko ein oder verlagern Sie
Ihre Zahlungsströme
ich würde wirklich gerne zurück nach
China ich bin jetzt aufgrund von Kowitz
seit zwei Jahren hier und nicht dort zu
sein macht es wirklich schwer die
Investments zu kontrollieren vor allem
in der frühen Phase wenn der Fokus auf
Support durch neue Infrastruktur oder
Software liegt
im Moment arbeitet jeder so gut er kann
remote sodass es nicht wirklich darauf
ankommt ob man tatsächlich vor Ort ist
die meisten unserer Investitionen wurden
in letzter Zeit vor allem im Silicon
Valley getätigt
wir haben in data bricks investiert wir
haben in FTX investiert das sind beides
Global Player die sowohl mit als auch
ohne China ihren Geschäften nachgehen
es ist interessant dass die FTX erwähnen
das Unternehmen hat ja erst vor kurzem
seinen Hauptsitz von Hongkong auf die
Bahamas verlegt auch zum Teil wegen
dieser harten Sanktionen deshalb frage
ich mich wie sich das auf lange Sicht
auswirken wird ich meine denken Sie die
chinesische Regierung wird einige dieser
Beschränkungen wieder lockern
und langfristig die Strategie Chinas ist
wie wirkt sich das ihrer Meinung nach
auf die Technologiesparte aus
ich denke die Technologiesparte muss
lernen sich an die neuen Regeln zu
halten egal wie groß ein Unternehmen ist
und besonders in diesem Jahr ist das
Gesetz zum Schutz der Privatsphäre von
entscheidender Bedeutung ich denke als
Investor in muss man sich dessen bewusst
sein
wir sollten unsere Anlagestrategie nicht
allein davon abhängig machen was in
China passiert es gibt noch jede Menge
Potenzial weil dieser Markt so gewaltig
groß ist ich glaube auch dass bestimmte
Branchen eher für Venture Capital in
Betracht kommen da man dort nicht so
viel mit sensiblen Daten zu tun hat wie
etwa die Bau- oder Gesundheitsbranche
daher müssen gerade wir als Investor in
den einfach die Augen offen halten und
schauen was in China passiert
aber was ist insbesondere mit
kryptowährungen ich meine wie Sie wissen
ist der Handel sowie das mining in China
illegal ist der kryptosektor denn nicht
viel stärker durch das harte
durchgreifen betroffen wie wirkt sich
das auf ihre Investitionen aus in wasing
so tolle always have a love have
relationship recrypto China und
kryptowährungen das war schon immer eine
Art Hassliebe 2008 war China noch die
Nummer eins der kryptoindustrie und
führte das Krypto Meiningen und den
krypto-handel an
since Tony 18
2017 kam dann das Verbot zu icos 2018
dann das Verbot zum Tausch von Fiat zu
Krypto beinens wurde dann 2019 der
kryptohandel verboten bis schließlich
dieses Jahr das Krypto mining und der
Handel generell verboten wurden was ich
damit sagen möchte ist dass vom ersten
Tag der Restriktion der Preis für
Bitcoin um etwa 3.000 Dollar gefallen
ist laut coin Gecko liegt der Preis für
Bitcoin aktuell bei etwa 60.000
ich denke dass das harte durchgreifend
Chinas gegen kryptowährungen in gewisser
Weise das Krypto Ökosystem wieder ins
Gleichgewicht bringt und langfristig
gesehen eine gute Sache für das
blockchain Ökosystem ist
[Musik]
im Nachhinein wird deutlich wie resolut
China gegen Bitcoin und andere
kryptowährungen vorgeht während die
Politik der Volksrepublik in Bezug auf
BTC in den ersten Jahren durch abwarten
und beobachten gekennzeichnet war
scheint sich die ablehnende Haltung
aufgrund zunehmender Popularität von
Krypto immer mehr zu manifestieren
zahlreiche Quellenverweise darauf dass
dies mit der Bekämpfung einer möglichen
Kapitalflucht zu tun haben könnte
darüber hinaus ist seit langem bekannt
dass China an einer eigenen digitalen
Währung arbeitet die zentral in den
Händen der Behörden liegt und im Prinzip
wie herkömmliches Fiat Geld
funktionieren soll nur eben elektronisch
wie die Nachrichtenagentur dpa berichtet
ist der digitale hören in seiner
Entwicklung weit fortgeschritten und
wird bereits in einigen Bereichen
eingesetzt es ist daher nicht
verwunderlich dass die chinesische
Regierung alles daran setzt die
krypto-konkurrenz zu verbieten
auch während der corona-pandemie
wiederholte die chinesische Regierung
ihre Ablehnung von Bitcoin und anderen
kryptowährungen und ging härter gegen
illegale kryptoaktivitäten vor dabei
führte sie stets den Kampf gegen Betrug
und Geldwäsche als Grund für das
vehemente Vorgehen an immer mehr
ausländische Websites wurden von
krypto-börsen blockiert um inländische
anleger:innen vom Handel mit
kryptowährungen abzuhalten und sie so
vor den Risiken des unregulierten
Handels mit cyberwährung zu schützen
im Mai 2021 bekräftigte die chinesische
Regierung ihre Absicht hart gegen das
mining von kryptowährungen vorzugehen
seitdem haben zahlreiche Bitcoin mining
Unternehmen beschlossen das Land der
Mitte zu verlassen und sich in anderen
Ländern wie zum Beispiel in den USA
niederzulassen
vor einigen Monaten wurde das
ursprüngliche cyber-thema wieder
aufgegriffen als die peoples Bank of
China alle Transaktionen im Zusammenhang
mit kryptowährungen als illegal erklärte
[Musik]
auch wenn die kryptowährungen auf jedes
hier beschriebene Ereignis stets mit
starken Kursschwankungen reagieren
scheint der Aufwärtstrend von Bitcoin
ungebrochen zu sein es bleibt abzuwarten
ob dies auch weiterhin der Fall sein
wird
[Musik]